before they just decrease the standard
there were women who did pass but your
question is hitting all women
statistically almost nothing
almost none that's not none okay great
said why do we lower the standards
[Music]
oh yeah I disagree with that
that's absolutely horrible that's
horrible
you're the king of the women's school
that's cool
welcome to the latest edition of change
my mind where we all hopefully
rationalize our positions on seemingly
controversial topics the latest topic is
the idea that women should not be in
roles of combat and this topic actually
took me to the Texas Women's University
now hold on I know what you're thinking
going to a Women's University to discuss
a subject featuring women specifically
is asking for trouble and I thought so
too after all sharing your opinions on
this topic
get you into some serious trouble right
well you wouldn't be the only one to
have those thoughts in fact a
substantial number of people thought the
exact same thing do you think most women
on this campus would agree with your
position absolutely absolutely not you
just rolled your eyes I just saw that
included sounds like maybe you're tired
of that a little bit a little bit yeah
foreign
opinion so will the cancel mob be
effective or can people feel free to sit
down and actually discuss their
positions I'll let you be the judge of
that now first up we have Olivia a
former High School wrestler and current
Texas women student now I bring you
Olivia first because you'll see later on
a young lady named Ploy who is also a
wrestler with very differing opinions
based on her experiences so let's
juxtapose that first with Olivia here
unchanged my mind do you mind scooching
ninja so we can kind of don't have to
reach out and hold us here for you
Olivia Stephen nice to meet you how do
you spell I'm willing about it
did I not say oh I don't think what did
I say I I think you said o oh no I said
oh oh I didn't say no
o-l-i-v-i-a right okay
um I don't know how familiar you are if
at all with the change in my mind uh
kind of format but it's basically a way
for us to rationalize our positions on
seemingly controversial topics to
clarify my stance today um yeah I don't
believe that women I use the term women
here because it is exclusively for women
that we've lowered uh PT requirements
and standards and barriers to entry in
the military and the police force as far
as enlisted Services as far as combat
roles infantry for example beat cops
um so that's why I use that example uh I
don't believe that they should be in
roles of physical combat where they
would encounter violence for multitude
of reasons largely because of safety
issues both for them but more
importantly they're Squad mates and the
citizens they're sworn to protect if you
disagree with me I'm more than happy to
hear why and change my mind all right so
um
I know you said like your main concern
with it is the woman joining are
lowering the PT requirements so I don't
know the military has lowered it so they
can join yeah I don't necessarily think
that um
that should mean that women should not
be in combat roles I mean if your
problem with that is that the the PT
requirements are being lowered I think I
don't think the PT requirement should be
lowered okay because
um like I and I know that would mean
that like technically less women would
be able to join yeah it does because
like testosterone and stuff but I don't
feel like that should mean that like
just women shouldn't be in combat roles
in general because there are those like
exceptions of women who are just like oh
sorry women who are just like naturally
stronger or bigger or like stuff like
that that would be able to keep up with
the natural PT requirements and just
like there's men that can't keep up with
PT requirements sure that's why there's
um that's why like when you're looking
at like officers or like military or
police they're typically held at the
standard because they're um they're able
to keep up with the requirements but not
women actually that's the problem
they're held to a much lower standard um
but I would agree with you so it sounds
like you're suggesting a physical
meritocracy which is if you pass the
tests then you should be able to okay
and I understand that would mean that
like I would agree with joy yes well we
went from two percent of women in the
70s to 16 and we've lowered the PT
requirements consistently and even just
recently in the Army created a gender
neutral test that less than 10 percent
of men failed and 65 of women feel this
is still a really low test I mean yeah
sorry I mean there are no more
testosterone and like right but it
sounds like you're saying they shouldn't
be lowering those tests we should have
the rigorous test that we did we should
if women met those they could be in
those rooms yeah and I like I said I
would understand that there'd be a lot
of women that wouldn't be able to make
it sure but um
right the men who don't meet those
standards shouldn't be in either men and
women who wouldn't be able to make it
right but um I think I think that my
problem with the statement is just it
was very broad because like um there's
always exceptions and there's a there's
a lot of women that I could just think
off at the top of my head that could
make it well there
I would bet you it's not a lot off the
top of your head uh at least five
at least five you think these you think
these women could do the same amount of
pull-ups as men in the Marines maybe
maybe close I'm not sure I don't I
wouldn't know them on a personal level
but oh on a personal I was going to say
oh okay I'll just say very very few for
example right now in the Marines this
stat kind of blew my mind as a woman in
the Marines can do half as many pull-ups
as a man and get a perfect score and
that's not the only standard I'm using
I'm just using it because it's very
clear metric
um but when we're talking about this uh
the reason this is brought is because
legislatively the only reason that our
standards have been lowered to the point
of them being frankly kind of
embarrassing for our military is to
accommodate women
um we haven't changed them you know the
beauty of a physical meritocracy is it's
blind whether it's race gender you pass
the test or you don't but we have
lowered the standards throughout all
branches the military and in a lot of
police forces to accommodate women they
still fail at a much higher rate anyway
and get put on the force as a result
they're hurt more uh they get injured
more if they're female cops they get
violently attacked more so do their
squad mates so if we're talking about
yes or individuals exceptions sure but
they could have made the cut a long time
ago not enough of them could so we
lowered the standards and that's what I
have an issue with this legislatively it
is exclusively for women well so
I feel like does that clarify though
yeah I know I like I I agree with you
there because I don't like like you said
lowering the PT standards could result
in just like injuries for themselves and
the squad mates and just like the people
they're trying to protect in general
right so my only my only issue with the
statement is it just said women like and
obviously I knew that's just like a
broad statement so like so it's hard to
fit it all on the side yeah because from
1971 to this you know we went from less
push-ups to no push-ups we went from
pull-ups to less pull-ups to no pull-ups
too not even doing a leg tuck like
that's tough to fit on a sign but that's
the policy of the militaries to be more
inclusive and to be more inclusive
inclusion should matter for
um things like like I get like people
want like inclusion and hearing their
representation like stuff like that but
like when it comes to like like serious
you just rolled your eyes I just saw
that included like maybe you're tired of
that a little bit a little bit Yeah but
um I'm saying when it comes to like
things like the military the PT
standards I don't think they should be
dropped because even though that'll mean
technically less women will be able to
join I think the ones that would join
would be the ones that actually belong
and like would be able to keep up right
and like actually like do their job
professionally and that was that was a
policy for a long time yeah but because
of progressive legislation yeah I don't
agree that that should have changed I
think the um I don't think you should
lower the limits for other people to be
able to join like I don't think like a
man who wouldn't be able to do it
shouldn't join I don't think a woman who
can't do it shouldn't join and that man
should preferably be laughed at yeah no
I'm not laughed at but like um mildly
ashamed hey let me ask you because it
sounds like we agree we found Common
Ground Olivia you have a USA Wrestling
shirt do you wrestle yeah oh okay do you
wrestle here for the school
um no no I'm I tore my laboring pretty
bad oh I might join next year I'm not
sure the wrestling team here at the
school yeah there's actually some
wrestlers over there oh wow fantastic
well that's another example uh take the
best female wrestler yeah right who you
can picture I would coach okay the coach
how would she fare against a man of her
size average in high school like an
average high school man I mean an
average man her age size and who would
be in her cat in her bracket
so
are you like um can I get like a like a
view on what this man's like
um like is he like a novice like because
she she was an Olympic bronze medalist
so she pretty much knows what she's
doing
um you ever watched Kayla Harrison
world's hobbyist men she was a she was a
judo gold medalist twice or uh who was
it Sarah McMahon thought Ronda Rousey
she was a silver medalist
um as someone who's done submission it's
not even close it's not even close
for a woman but the strength difference
so that's actually a topic that I'm like
really like
what's the word passionate about passion
yeah let me let me let me hear it
because you do have men go biological
men going into women's wrestling because
that's that I hate that and I know a lot
of people want to be like it's inclusion
matter matters but
by taking like biological men and
allowing them to compete in women's
sports you're taking away from the
biological woman because you're gonna
have all these biological men dominating
the categories of course and then you'll
confront someone about that and you'll
be like well if it's just a coincidence
and if testosterone doesn't play a big
role in this then how is it every
they'll go from like the like 150th and
best in the men's category and then
instantly to the person rights category
like there's a reason we have a men's
division and a women's division I agree
no and that's why we're here today
because I've done women's men should not
compete in women's sports biological
mention not competing women's sports and
boy was I met with screeching from
people but take that and instead of
wrestling because most sports are sort
of right their their analogous to war
that's what I mean football you look at
sort of gaining territory so take the
wrestling component which we both agree
on it's unfair then apply it to them
going out into the front lines and
they're fighting other men so it's like
taking a woman's wrestling team and
putting them against for example Syria's
men's wrestling yeah that's why I said
um you need to take big like not just
like an average woman it'd have to be
more of like an elite woman to be able
to join combat positions like without
lowering the PT standards right yeah I
agree and even then it would still be
you'd still be few and far between it
would be it would be a way smaller
amount but it would be the amount that
needs to be there hey do you want to
hear a step that might blow your mind it
says actually specifically as it relates
to grappling so I was looking at the
strength differential
since we found common ground you're very
I hope you feel we've been both been
respectful and enjoyable it's a nice
it's a welcome break from some of the
people on this campus uh so you know uh
there are these studies you can find and
they were largely conducted in Japan
that a woman is 60 as strong as a man
and I was thinking like that doesn't
sound right and then when I looked it up
these were studies in Japan and there's
a very big difference between for
example Nordic you know males and
females and that are much bigger than
the women than Japanese and men are to
Japanese women these were very limited
instances of like a leg press you know
where they would sort of measure the
actual contractile strength of the
muscle but not in a practical fashion so
in that same study I believe on that
paper at least they measured grip
strength and you know this is important
in wrestling it's particularly important
in Judo because you're grabbing fabric
most women are weaker in their grip than
95 of men but they took women from Judo
from wrestling from Olympic
weightlifting the most elite Olympic
athletes female athletes and their grip
strength was still weaker than 75
percent of men the strongest women that
did surprise me I'm not like I'm not
denying that like I know but isn't that
kind of surprising like wouldn't you
think I mean you're an Olympic Athlete
would be like less than 75 of men's grip
like that's crazy too shocked because
like I I think like because of like TV
and like all like the um like the roles
that like certain like like women are
put in where they like just have like
they beat up Five Guys yeah they have
like a chick beat up
it becomes like kind of like a like a
normal thing to think about oh yeah a
woman beat up five guys but if you
really think about it I don't think a
lot of people think about
um like what testosterone can do yeah
like and like but there is like there is
a difference between men and women yeah
when it comes to um not just
testosterone but like the average man
luteinizing hormone right follicle
stimulating hormone you look at
everything with men like the bone yeah
no but no you're absolutely right and I
think uh look I think what you've said
is very reasonable I think it's a woman
with skin in the game because you know
you wrestle whatever and I've been
asking I've actually met quite a few um
uh women here who've really been
wonderful to speak with I would ask you
not forcing it it's not patriarchy that
you present your reason viewpoints on a
campus where they would be less than
popular when women bring up the kind of
arguments that I encounter we need women
like you who are well spoken who
understand the differences to be able to
speak out because I do think that a lot
of women are afraid if they have a
differing opinion from what they're
supposed to have a lot of girls have
expressed that today and um and that
makes me sad
because men aren't afraid to bust each
other's balls women are generally nicer
yeah
you're wrestling I hope are you getting
surgery I already got it did it work
yeah you know I don't think it does but
did they do it is it less mobile because
I had to tighten it a little bit Yeah
I'm still working on that
yeah that happened I don't know if you
saw TJ Dillashaw fought recently and he
had a shoulder reconstruction and it
just popped out in the fight in the UFC
he was a good wrestler and that's tough
to recover from but if it's just your
labrum back here I've seen people yeah
it turned into a SLAP tear though so
they said the yeah it might be a little
more complicated yeah now all right well
God speed with it Olivia I appreciate it
thank you for sitting down I really do
appreciate it well that's always a nice
start and take care of that labrum
Olivia Hope you're back in the mat soon
that brings us to another female
wrestler Ploy and let's just say there
was a bit more disagreement during this
exchange so uh Ploy Stephen nice to meet
you nice to meet you and how is Ploy
spelled um p-l-o-i p-l-o-y one and two
shot of getting it right with why your
eye I thought it was I I didn't want to
risk it so uh Ploy I don't know uh how
familiar you are if it all was kind of a
change of mind segments but it's
designed to hopefully allow people to
rationalize their positions on seemingly
controversial topics it's been largely
respectful to every single conversation
it's been pretty productive so I'm happy
about that seems that there's a shift
that's been taking place the
conversation today
I do not believe that women biological
women should be in combat roles meaning
enlisted Services uh for example police
roles that would involve violent
altercations because of the fact that
they are not only physically less
capable but it also brings up safety
issues as it relates to not only
themselves but their brothers in arms
and I say women just because it could be
men who don't meet these PT requirements
either but we've only systematically
lowered the standards in our military
police force for women and they fail
anyway and I think that's a bad thing so
I was talking to the guy over there
before about it and my take was on so I
think it's an issue based on the format
on how we test it between men and women
rather than it being an issue between
men and women because
the example I used is so I'm a wrestler
I'm on the wrestling team in my school
I'm here I wrestle right there yeah
Olivia was she one of your friends she
no I don't
um but um so I went I came from I'm from
New York I was on a boys team we always
start off every year with 60 guys okay
let's say including me 60 people end of
the year always 20.
for me it was always like I asked him I
was like okay so let's say we raise the
standard let's say because your issue
right now is you're saying that people
the standings are lowering because
they're allowing more women in so they
have to have lower distance so just to
be clear let me just be really clear is
they had a standard right women didn't
pass it so we went from two percent of
the enlisted forces are you saying no
woman passed it at all very very few
very few so there are women who pass it
right okay but then we lowered them we
created two separate standards okay male
and female standards for example like in
the Marines a woman can do half as many
pull-ups okay and get a perfect score
okay which I think is awesome then we
created a gender neutral test okay less
than 10 of men fail still 65 of women so
no matter how much we continue to lower
the test where we eliminate for example
pull-ups in the Army we eliminate
push-ups entirely uh we change the times
required for both men and women uh women
still fail at a higher rate so all the
physical metrics that we've used we've
lowered Four Women and it hasn't had
good results
okay but here's the thing you're saying
that there are you're saying very few
but there are women who pass sure okay
your ques your question is right now is
women should not do any Combat Sports
are you including the woman who did pass
I didn't say Combat Sports you said I'm
sorry combat rolls my bad combat rules
yeah no if we're if we're saying if for
example if your position is hey if we
return to the standards of the 70s for
example the same exact standards that
were required of men and women met those
sure let's say yes then you would um
disagree with the statement I I would
disagree it would be based on real world
data because we don't here's the thing
we don't have the data from those women
right we do have the data from the lower
standards
two times the bone fracture right right
uh 65 higher physical disability
discharge rates for every percentage
point you increase a squad of police
with women every percentage point of
women that you add to it the chances of
them being the victim of violence all
the entire Squad goes up 20 so we don't
have the real world data of those Elite
capable women
but if we did return to those standards
and the data would bear out that they
were just as capable I would have no
problem but wouldn't it be an argue not
on women then and based on you're saying
like the standards have lowered so much
wouldn't that be the issue on the
standards yeah well so that's a very
valid point now here's the issue here's
why I say women okay I do believe I
think you're suggesting a physical
meritocracy but if you pass the test if
you hit the requirements you should be
able to join them yeah legislatively we
haven't lowered them based on race we
haven't lowered them based on the age
we've only lowered them for women and so
legislatively it's that those women
shouldn't be in combat there are plenty
of women right now in combat roles
who are supremely unqualified and they
make their squad mates uh they put them
in danger not to mention our country I'm
not going to argue whether your
statement biologically is true or false
I do believe women and men have a
difference biologically my only problem
is that your question is hitting to all
women what about the woman who do pass
without the woman who I'm not saying
okay but if they do they're questioning
your statistics because I don't know
because I don't know whether your
statistics are true or false but I'm
saying that
before they dis decreased the standard
there were women who did pass but your
question is hitting all women
statistically almost none
almost done that's not none okay great
then why don't we lower the standards
I personally don't know I don't think we
should have if you're talking to me I
think
fingers when you're talking about the
military I think there is there should
be more money going into like you know
training I know that right now training
with diffusing situations isn't very
good there is barely any training on
that there's barely any training with
guns and thoroughly any training like in
the police force I don't know about the
military I'm not very like familiar with
that but I know the training isn't as
good as it could be and I feel like for
me
I feel like my problem like I came here
for this like to talk to you it's more
like one my problem is with the question
because I feel like the question is way
too generalized that's not a question
that's a statement the statement is too
generalized I'm sorry and I just feel
like
my issue is more with you're saying the
standard rather than the biology yes but
I've hopefully
let me try and clarify again we have
only legislatively because of the modern
feminist movement lowered the standards
which I believe is sexist because women
are weaker and less capable than men so
we have only lowered them for women we
haven't lowered them for anyone else and
that's a bad thing so the reason that
I'm saying women is because this applies
exclusively the lower standards applies
exclusively to women
I have a question from a government does
that clarify that does clarify yeah
little things but my only question that
I brought up to him is that you said a
little thing what does it not clarify
oh no sorry it clarifies it for me I
mean I have a little thing okay sorry I
apologies that um I need to clarify it's
I argued with him I said could you say
that because of the technological
advancements we have today in the
military and the in artillery that there
is a less physical demand here's that
one what sorry did you have where I
could I could address that I was gonna
say and you're saying combat roles but
there are a lot of combat rules that
don't necessarily need as much physical
demand well that's why I clarified I
said physical combat roles where you
would encounter violence so I have no
problem for example I'm not completely
physical well I have no problem for
example with women in the police force
uh for example being interrogators uh
forensic evidence detectives these are
much these are very important roles
these are pivotals in the military for
example combat roles aside from the
reflexes where women are not quite as
quick as men they tend to make very
proficient Pilots I don't have no
problem with that I still don't have any
problem with Intel officer roles or if
it's for example drone operation where
these tests can be blind right the issue
is the tests for physical combat
Readiness are not blind they're
inherently I argue sexist and that they
are embarrassingly low for women and the
real world so we might say sure there
are technological advancements it
doesn't change the fact that the bone
fracture rate is astronomical for women
the second you put them under load
bearing which makes sense because of
less bone mineral than City the fact
that they're discharged for physical
disability at a rate much higher than
men and also by the way several
multiples higher to be discharged with
PTSD to require psychotropic medication
so there is a psychological component
where we've also lowered some of those
standards exclusively for women I
believe that's inherently sexist but
more importantly it doesn't make us a
safer fighting force to lower those
standards but we've only done it for
women
okay for the when you're talking about
psychologically I feel like there is
just like I feel like it is sexist
towards men I do feel like men should be
taken as seriously when it comes to
mental health military as women are and
I feel like there is both issues with
both sides but that may be true but my
thing is now so you're saying you're
talking about physical combat rules so
instead of saying the statement woman
should not be doing combat roles would
you say it is true to instead say women
should not be doing physical combat
roles because the thing is you're saying
you agree
yeah when I sat down but the thing is
at the end of the day those combat roles
are still combat rules they might not be
as physical to many but they are still
combat roles
well like I said were any physical
combat rules they were encounter in
counties for us women should not be on
the beat women should not be out there
where they're going to deal with the guy
my size on PCP absolutely not even if
you are an I.T even if you are like when
you are in the military you're at risk
I'm talking about police force because I
think it's more clear here
now it's in the military no but I've
said combat roles and I've said both
police force when I sat down so if
you're talking about drones that's
technically combat I was very clear in
saying let me restate I'm not saying
that women cannot be in the military I'm
not saying that women cannot be in the
police force I'm saying that lowering
the standards as we have done decade
after decade after decade to increase
female recruitment as part of a
diversity agenda has resulted in more
violence against women and a less
capable military police were so in the
in the police force we're not talking
about drones we're talking about being
out there having to apprehend someone
physically
women shouldn't be in those roles why do
you think they want more women in the
first place than like if there's this
argument why do you think when they want
more women in the first place because we
have this asinine obsession with
diversity
I think it's more like
into today's society there are less and
less men that want to join the military
and they need higher numbers that's what
my think is well here's what's
interesting about that because I
actually went down a rabbit hole
um I've heard this argument there's a
recruiting crisis but as we have
increased the percentage of recruits in
women two percent to about 16 in
enlisted forces uh women make up about
13 of the police force it's a little bit
harder to measure because municipalities
use different numbers okay but they've
increased just clarification
or military I'm giving you both okay two
percent of 16 let me let me really break
it down so I don't do the workplace two
percent of 16 of listen forces
gone to 13 women police okay let's
remain stagnant it's about two thousand
but increased dramatically as that
number has gone up women we've lowered
requirements that's when we Face the
recruitment crisis now I'm not saying
it's because women have been enlisted
but it unequivocally cannot be argued
that recruiting more women increases our
capacity to recruit the inverse is true
correlation doesn't equal causation but
it cannot be argued that including more
women increases recruits it decreases
okay or at least a decrease occurs as we
simultaneously increase female recruits
I have my theories as to why that's the
case but it's not observable in data I'd
be making an inference but the data is
what it is so going back to the police
force well usually he said you wrestle
right
um and here's it is it Freestyle
Wrestling yeah wrestling yeah you
wrestled in high school yes so folk
style uh yeah well I did freestyle too
did you do freestyle okay do you do any
Greco-Roman as well I know that's more
International no no
um my club did do it I did a little but
I never competed in it I didn't like it
yeah I know it's a little bit different
when you take away the any of the leg
attacks it's a totally different sport
not my type of thing yeah a lot of
suplexing um oh I love suplexing just
not Greco-Roman well I'm saying it's
almost exclusively suplex Roman right
you don't do any what's your favorite
takedown what do you usually use I like
going for a high Crush only going for
icar Studio yeah do you go in there from
like a low single and kind of ride it up
to high across do you chain it or do you
just shoot High crunch I don't think you
can hit a low single to a high crotch
because then you'd go behind for a low
single no a little single you go down
for like an ankle pick where you're
going to ride up to the hot crutch I
don't like that because short anyway I
just like going right for the legs a
friend of mine actually UFC fighter
Daniel Cormier that's his go-to is a
high crotch single
just interesting to me
we have had this for example in
wrestling um
you're in college now yes you wrestle
any of the men
um nope I did last year only until
recently it's my first time ever being
on a woman's team oh okay I've been
completely it was we had for the first
time ever we had a girl on my team
besides me but for the most part I've
always been the only girl okay in club
and in school
well I had two friends yeah and in
college is a little bit different how do
women fare with the men in college
wrestling if it's the same weight class
same division I don't I haven't Wrestled
a guy in college it's well because
there's we don't even wrestle the same
style so we can't wrestle each other
like why do you think women don't
wrestle with men
um because we wrestle freestyle and they
wrestle folk style it's a completely
different there's plenty of male
freestyle wrestlers in college
not not certainly at the club level yeah
at a club level but collegially we're
not allowed to okay so but why at a club
level do you think women don't wrestling
I mean they do my friend um um she
qualified for Fargo under Greco-Roman
for men why do you think that as a rule
when we're creating women's divisions
and men's divisions and wrestling uh for
example NCAA champion
International wrestling
um
why do women not wrestleman
can you do the word play here why do
women not wrestle men it's not a trick
question the thing is I can't really
answer that question because I fuss with
men my whole life this is my first time
ever not wrestling men so I can't say
why I don't because I do and you're the
only woman in the history of wrestling
who beat them consistently no there are
no they're not I want you to restate
your questions one more time I'm sorry
would you be the only woman in history
who in a high level of wrestling
consistently beat men in your age weight
and skill bracket no because there are
girls better than me who have beaten
guys
in your age skill and weight bracket on
a national level name me one female who
won a national championship I know
Heaven should [ __ ] one state in South
Carolina I don't remember what year was
I was pretty young at that time
um that's her full name I know a bunch
of different double a shoot All American
you're talking about college wrestling
college wrestling or college age Club
wrestling there aren't any females or
males who wrestle together in college
age because that's when you get
separated to my question that's why I
asked why do they not you said they do I
said I did in high school no but I said
College club or college you said it was
a different style I'm gonna friend us
again Collegiate level wrestling
you said I was wrong I said why do women
not wrestle men you said they do so now
you're saying I'm gonna go back to high
school high school is very different at
a high level why are there no women take
Sarah McMahon silver medalist right
fought Ronda Rousey
not even that's I don't even know what
that is WWE I don't so she's she's a
silver medalist in the Olympics and
wrestling oh
who was a bronze medalist in Judo Kayla
Harrison and these are people who have
been on my program I feel Harrison
two-time Olympic gold medalist in Judo
um and on the program I say this because
when we both agree that the only
American to ever win a gold medal in
Judo and she won two probably qualified
to discuss she said it wouldn't even be
close with men low-level hobbyist men
okay why is that I agree with that one
because I do agree I'd say in the
beginning there is a biological
difference between male and female
between muscle mass
not just muscle mass bone density fast
switch muscle fibers reflexes right so
we would agree there's a reason that
it's separate but when you said it to me
in the beginning I thought you meant in
general and I said I can't say that
because in high school I've only
wrestled meal I don't have the I'm sure
anyone can wrestle anybody I mean you
know you would I could find a mat and
yeah so it doesn't mean that it's
competitive when you say why don't I I
thought you meant like back then no I
said why don't women why do they
separate the divisions and I think we've
roundabout way to both agree that
they're a strong biological differences
between men and women there's a reason
that the divisions are separate and it's
not competitive so let's take wrestling
when I was talking with one of your
friends I believe or someone who
wrestled uh here or hasn't wrestled at
school yet she has a torn labrum it was
Olivia
um we were saying sports are sort of
allegorical analogous for war right in a
lot of ways it's a way of sort of
competing without killing each other so
take wrestling where we know it's not
even remotely competitive
now apply killing
we need the most effective fighting
force possible just like I wouldn't send
out a woman for example to wrestle kale
Sanderson uh I wouldn't send a woman who
can't do a pull-up and that's the
majority of female recruits in the
military I would not send her out to war
but she doesn't lose a match she loses
her life
and so does the guy next to her relying
on her
I think it's important more important
than diversity my again I'm going to
bring it back to the standard point I
think that's an issue with the standards
we have in the military in the police
force I think the standards aren't high
enough again I agree we can argue like
that there is a biological difference
but again you're also talking about
people have guns they have a lot of
technological advancements today's
military technologically is off the
charts like it is crazy how much money
we put into the military every single
day technologically advancing ourselves
sure
so
I actually agree with the statement you
just made I think it's very important
but you said for example guns
advancement let's just say in finance
that does equalize the playing field
right in a lot of ways okay so it's a
perfect example
for the same reason I support women
being able to carry firearms and
actually support them carrying firearms
because it's the only way to be stronger
than a man it's a mechanical advantage
right yes we have advances in Firearms
still the only way that a woman could
overpower a strong man
flips out of that coin in the police
force woman will have to use a firearm
she'll have to use a weapon because she
can't physically subdue a man and that I
don't believe is something where you
talk about de-escalation if you have to
go to your tool belt because you cannot
physically restrain a 250 pound man on
PCP but to you it's not a good thing you
have to because I'm saying between men
and women I'm
I don't remember the exact like number
so I can't really quote on this but I
know for a fact that there is not enough
training on de-escalation like they
barely do any training on it at all I
agree with the statement that I agree
with you they should train that robustly
okay I agree that you're saying like men
and women like women are physically
smaller we are biologically different
but I'm saying in general you can't put
the whole argument on just women rather
than putting it on a structural problem
right I have like a structural problems
because of the matriarchy and the
problem with feminism trying to lower
standards to accommodate women but can't
you say it's also sexism because it's
the idea that like I was saying before
like you were talking about in the
military how a lot of it is um there's a
lot of things given to women and it's
like the men should be um we're talking
about like for example mental health for
example now we were saying that like um
women are more like a PTSD be disjoint
it's also because men aren't treated
seriously for it because it's like that
that could be true it's an inference but
I I think your inference might be
correct yes
that could also be instead of saying
because of feminist it could also be
because of sex in them shorts man you
may be correct on that I think it's
probably a little column a little column
B I think we have quite a lot of data
that shows that men tend to perform
better
high compression stress scenarios than
women in general they're always
exceptions to the room
um and it tends to be more traumatic for
women and then especially when you
combine right sort of a being on the
receiving end of a traumatic injury in
the military same thing in the police
force
um but you mentioned de-escalation now
you're you do you wrestle so you have
some understanding of uh I would say
controlling or subduing the human body
right that's what sure all grappling
Arts are this Brazil you just do
Wrestling Judo
um I do believe that should be trained
in the police force so that you don't
have to use a weapon I think that we
need higher standards as a matter of
fact I think every member of the police
should have basic grappling capabilities
so that they don't have to for example
grab their gun and grab their taser now
de-escalation
I agree with you it's very important
here's what I would argue is a reality
of the escalation you can only
de-escalate if you have the nuclear
option what do I mean you can't
de-escalate with a large strong likely
inebriated man who doesn't want to go
back to prison is
a small weak woman trying to de-escalate
he knows that he has a trump card and he
can attack him statistically it happens
a lot de-escalation can only take place
with formidable capability and women
don't have that physically as a general
rule not all women and certainly most of
the women in our police force today
for me
okay I'm not disagreeing with your
statement I actually kind of agree with
your statement my only thing is again
like I said for de-escalation when I
think of de-escalation I think of more
like
you know like um Physical Therapy you
know how we learn about the cognitive
whatever like um yeah you've ever heard
about like you've ever um taken a
psychology class sure okay and they
teach us about like different things
about the human like behavior and things
like that I feel like
and the way I think about it is I feel
like cops should be taught that because
they should be taught how to behave and
be like not behave but you know how to
like I agree with what you're saying
yeah but
I think it's a very important component
of the job right I think it's a very
important one to be able to de-escalate
and to be fair most police civilian
interactions most of them are not
violence yeah but every single police
officer male or female will have many
violent interactions throughout their
country and only takes one
and if you're not physically up to the
task and the women in our police force
the vast majority are not not all of
them but the vast majority are not
that's a problem if I can let me give
you this is we've talked about the
empirical and anecdotal story okay and
uh I come from a backup done Judo
building it so we don't really have
wrestling in Canada uh Canadian
wrestling sorry I know it's not very
good yeah there's the Olympic team and
like Georgetown and then everyone else
there aren't very it doesn't happen in
high school uh but now I'm a new father
and um I've also coached kids and here's
the problem too we have a lot of moms
for example when they have sons uh they
will tell them if they're dealing with a
bully and I had this they said you walk
up to and you tell them they better stop
you know it needs to stop or else where
you tell them that he needs to stop that
this is you know he's just doing it
because he feels bad about himself in
other words whatever techniques that are
often told to young boys uh it doesn't
work if the bully knows he can kick your
ass that happened to me when I was young
I said well you know stop this is wrong
you need to stop doing this well he said
what and kicked my ass only once I was
able to physically defend myself could
escalate the situation then at that
point I could say look do you really
want to go this route and that's what we
actually teach children we teach
children we teach them Jiu Jitsu The
Graces actually do this it's important
we teach a psychology we say
avoid it and then if they continue to
harass you ask them are you challenging
me to a fight
so psychologically the bully has a
choice to make either yes in which case
you use what you know
or if he says most the time he'll say no
it's de-escalated but you can only ask
that question if you know the answer is
yes then you can handle it
women can't handle it if they're in an
inner city and a man is on PCP you can't
de-escalate from a position of weakness
does that make does that make sense kind
of
we didn't have nukes and we told Russia
you know we told Russia to stop it
I could care no no exactly so it doesn't
matter you can only have peace through
strength de-escalation if they know that
when push comes to shove there are
consequences and the statistics are
really scary women as far as being in
the receiving end of violent attacks
when they're police officers it's not
good
and I don't want to see that I don't
want to see women getting hurt because
of some diversity quota I don't think
that's a good thing for women and I
don't think it's a good thing for the
guy next to her my thing is I was
talking to him and where that guy went
but I was talking about something and we
were talking about how um police need to
be retrained we get trained they get
trained once and then they're they go
for the job men too I feel like over
time he was giving the example it wasn't
me he was saying like police officers
gets trained at a job freshly trained
whatever physically built whatever years
go by it gets fat he gets slow you know
he doesn't get retrained the training
basically just leaves his head
I feel like
if you're talking about like that it's
it's definitely the same it's like I
don't feel like no I agree I agree I
think that's terrible I just don't think
that the solution is a reverse Nirvana
fallacy well then let's just lower the
standards for everyone I think we need
to raise it I think we're both agreeing
we need to raise the standards let me
put it this way would you agree with me
and I've talked about this in the show
that not only should officers have to
display not only uh physical
capabilities as far as strength
endurance Being Fit they also should
have to display fiscal capabilities for
example in grappling
that as well they do have that but they
should have that as well and they should
be forced to re-pass an exam every year
I agree yes okay then I think we're
agreeing on the same thing my issue is
that exam can't be to a lower standard
for women right now it is okay I agree
with that I agree it shouldn't be lower
standard for women but the thing is I'm
saying again if a woman passes that exam
again that statement you're saying okay
you're saying there's not as many women
passing that exam but there are still
women passing that Sam well right now
there aren't women passing the exam for
men because they don't take it they have
a separate exam yeah but I'm saying
you're saying women shouldn't do it at
all but I'm saying if there if there is
a higher exam if it's the same as men
and if women pass it
or you take like are you saying if we
hold them to the highest standard
possible and the women you know the
probably one to two percent of women who
apply pass
and afterwards we would look at the real
world data and they're just as effective
in the police force or military I would
have no problem with it then I agree
with that statement that's the same I
agree with okay well thank you very much
it was it was uh what POI
I was close it's a tough name for me to
remember okay well thank you very much I
appreciate you sitting down and are you
wrestling this year yeah we actually
have a meet today tonight oh okay who
are you who are you guys wrestling each
other we're um having it's a because
it's our first year team we our coach is
Randy Miller she's a bronze Olympian oh
wow so good and actually I'm familiar
with Randy Miller
I don't know her personally
so I hope to make her you know she's
been training us and she hand-picked us
so I hope to make her proud well I don't
see this coach sorry coach hopefully
don't run into a bunch of you know
dagestanis or Eastern black people
because boy they are monsters in the
mess they grow up wrestling bears from
when they're three years old but uh yeah
I have quite a few friends who have gone
to International competitions more so
Greco-Roman because it's more practice
internationally and yeah it is a tough
tough sport so all the respect in the
world to you thank you thank you so much
thank you Floyd a little bit of
disagreement though I wouldn't say
contentious and I always appreciate
someone willing to step out of their
comfort zone hopefully some positions
might be reconsidered after the
conversation now our next guest was
really a bright spot in the day uh
because she brought something completely
new to this installment meet Jay Jay
Stephen nice to meet you nice to meet
you nice to meet you do you mind
scooting in just a little bit here okay
so Jay I know you've been waiting a
little while uh I don't know how
familiar you are with kind of these
segments what we do with change my mind
it's just hopefully an opportunity to
rationalize positions unseemingly
controversial topics surprisingly today
it hasn't seemed to be that
controversial they've all been
respectful thus far uh my position and
sometimes you can't fit it all in the
sign I do not believe that women uh
biological women should be in roles of
physical combat enlisted forces of
police force where they would encounter
fiscal violence uh simply because
they're more likely to be the victim of
violence they're less safe and so are
their brothers in arms uh and the people
are sworn to protect and legislatively
we have been systematically lowering the
barrier entry and physical and mental
requirements in order to accommodate
women in these enlisted forces I I think
that's a horrible course to be on if you
disagree with me I'm more than glad to
hear you change my mind I mean I'm more
here to just learn about the other side
um I mean
serving our country takes a lot of heart
to even begin to think about sure
um and I guess
my my I have family who served and I
really wanted to be Ground Control for
the Air Force a lot okay and then I flew
a teeny plane I was like yeah no I can't
do that what kind of plane did you fly
uh teeny little Cessna are you Cessna
182 yeah oh okay little little yellow
one yeah
um did you get your pilot's license oh
uh no my dad did though oh okay so you
did it illegally I guess maybe we
shouldn't okay let's just say it was
training courses it was yeah yeah
complete on the up enough
um but I mean I guess it's such a
difficult water to tread there's a lot
of obstacles
um either way
um and I really feel like just
let me ask you this what's the role of
our military
I'm protecting sir right so to do that
you need to be the most effective
fighting effective Protective Service
possible that's the goal yeah
yeah we're not accomplishing that by
lowering the physical standards and the
requirements to a point of frankly
becoming a national embarrassment
um in order to accommodate women that's
the only reason we do that's so I don't
think it's very complicated it's one
point we had standards for example that
involved uh load-bearing jogging to a
significant degree pull-ups push-ups set
up they've been eliminated in almost all
branches of the military a marine female
can do half as many pull-ups to achieve
a perfect score and the net result is uh
I think her bone fractures at a very
high rate they're discharge or physical
disability at a very high rate squads
are the results of the victims of
violence at a higher rate police squads
or the victims of violence at a much
higher rate when women are on the force
and that's because we've lowered the
requirements specifically to accommodate
women in the name of diversity would
have no problem if the standards were
where they always were and the select
few women met them just none of them did
statistically that's that's all it is it
doesn't mean by the way that women can't
for example be Ground Control or even
Pilots uh certainly in the police force
investigators perhaps negotiators
forensic evidence uh interrogators just
not on the beat where you have a fellow
Squad mate who was in physical Harm's
Way if you're not physically capable
that's all okay yeah that's unreasonable
well it's your point of view and so I
take it with as much respect as I take
mine what's your point I haven't I I'm
forgive me I don't understand your point
of view what's your point of view that
we should because here's the reality
right we've lowered physical
requirements to accommodate women they
still fail the vast majority of them
anyway we can't really lower them much
more but they're getting into the
military now with a much lower standard
and the results are bad I think that's
bad what's your point of view just why I
understand
um she never really thought about it
that much
I have your point of view established
and that's okay well that's part of why
I'm here is to see how that stands up
against something else that I'm not
familiar with well I mean can I ask you
something why do you think you're
unfamiliar with my stance because it's
shared by at least half the country uh
well I've um I've not really taken a lot
of consideration myself in being in the
forces and so I haven't really looked
personally at what that could look like
for me or someone like me
um and
um I know women who have served and
fought and men who have served and
fought so my general consensus is that
they served you know so to me it's
really not that much about it
um
I guess um for me it would depend person
to person and that would I guess it
would really create a lot of problems
and I do see that
um with individualizing someone who's
serving so much
um based on all these different things
like I know I'm in qualifiable because
I'm tiny you could shoot a bazooka and
I'd go flying you know if you shut up
and look at me I'd go flying that's kind
of the purpose of a bazooka I don't
think any of us would survive Oh you
mean if you fired it oh okay
um but um I do believe that with such
um
such a difficult task of serving your
country in any sense I mean it could be
taxing even if you're not
um in a combatant role sure
um fit physically mentally
psychologically uh
and so I guess really
um
that's why we shouldn't individualize it
we should have standardized it yeah
I can see to me I think it should really
be
um I guess gosh
it's cool to be on the spot like this
because now I really get to like think
about it
um always
I think well
I guess there are I guess there are a
lot of people who can't really serve in
a combatant role sure and so I think
generally
um you know because there are yeah there
are there are men who are disabled there
are a lot of different people who can't
fight for a lot of different reasons
right
um but I think instead of at least for
me personally
instead of worrying about
um the kind of people we put in we can
focus on how we can make them the best
even if that might mean
uh talking to them and saying hey we
know you're interested in this but this
might be a better fit and that doesn't
necessarily mean that we can bar them in
a combatant sense
but yeah I'm on a personal level though
the requirements if they don't meet them
bar them yeah yeah that makes sense
because if you can't throw a grenade
or you can't carry you know you can't
carry a certain load it is the same
amount of distance in the same amount of
time without you know unfortunately oh a
bone fracture yeah um or you know you
can't do a leg tuck so we go to a plank
yeah that's no one's no one's
discriminating against them if the test
is standardized that's why I think it
has to be standardized and by the way it
is at the end of training you know so we
do training we train them and then you
just test to see if they're fit
um so even with training there's a lot
of women are still not fit and so we
keep lowering those standards so they're
not being disqualified personally the
test is disqualified okay for the same
reason that a man in a wheelchair
doesn't mean that you're being ableist
if you say well you probably shouldn't
be out in the front lines why because
you'll be killed yeah yeah I don't want
him killed I think that
um to eliminate the
possibility of combating a loan like
just as a baseline I think could take
away opportunity for growth because
someone could come in maybe not being
able to lift but over time they could
develop that ability
you know obviously how about once they
develop that ability and they pass the
test they can go in they shouldn't be
learning on the job
if they're given
if they're given ample time and
resources to train in and out of that
setting equally then I believe that I
believe the test you know there's
nothing stopping any woman right now
from training up to meet basic
requirements you can do your push-ups
you can do your sit-ups you can go do
your job with a backpack you know you
could you could do your your pull-ups on
a tree on a park there's nothing
stopping it's not a lack of resources
it's a biological ceiling if they can do
it they can do it if they can do it I
agree yeah vast majority of women can't
so we keep lowering the standards and
that's my issue and certainly with the
police force you know I think that when
we're dealing with people complaining
about in some cases very Justified
police brutality the same reason I
support women carrying firearms because
a firearm makes a woman like you just
said you're small uh you're as strong as
a man if you know how to operate a
firearm I understand as strong as a man
in a different capacity
no I'm talking about in a physical
altercation there's no way that a man
will not overpower you for example yeah
it's an average size man but you have a
firearm it equalizer it's called The
Brave equalizer for a reason right in
that same capacity right in other words
you can use your firearm if a woman is
physically less capable as a cop
she has to use her firearm
that will increase the likelihood of
police brutality let alone of course the
incidence of violent attacks against
women in the police force and their
brothers in arms and it's much higher so
for the same reason that I like women
civilians to be able to carry firearms
the flip side of that coin is I want
female police officers to not have to
use their firearms unfortunately it's a
biological reality that they do if
they're dealing with you know a guy my
size on PCP you're going to need to use
a gun and I don't want to see women
getting killed and getting beaten up out
there yeah so
um well I appreciate you sitting down it
was it was uh Jay Jay that's right it's
not Joe Jake thank you Jay I really
appreciate you taking the time thank you
and uh maybe we'll be back here sometime
and you can let me know what you
get your pilot's license too you know
there's there's not a lot of Pilots
there's a real opening right now oh yeah
yeah another really easy you know it's
like it's a really good field to go into
there's there's a serious lack of Pilots
so private planes
um they pay well I know a guy a wealthy
guy who has a plan yeah there are not
enough Pilots out there and actually
women make great Pilots um that's why I
actually had this ready but we didn't
disagree that women in the Air Force
actually do incredibly well
um because of how they sustain g-forces
sometimes uh so just consider it I'm
just saying it's an option if you like
flying it's a potential career thank you
so much thank you Jay appreciate it
now I don't want to speak out of turn I
think that might have been a change in
my mind first in that Jay didn't really
seem to have any opinions at least
strong opinions one way or the other but
was willing to sit down and I appreciate
her willingness to do so which by the
way is why we always make all the
references available at louder with
crowder.com you can click the link in
the description to peruse at will and
learn more on this topic also if you
enjoy this series and want them to
continue please consider commenting
below which topic you'd like to see next
on change my mind and hit that like
button so that YouTube can throttle this
anyway okay next up we have oh uh Anaya
Anaya or Anaya Anaya Anaya okay I
apologize if I get your name wrong
because I'm horrible with names but I'll
never forget your face I have a weird
facial recognition software I get it I I
do the same are you the same way yeah
you remember faces with the name like
yeah so in my mind I'll go annihilator
so that then I'll remember your name but
I might accidentally say Annihilator I
get it it's okay
um
we have someone here a nice Stephen nice
to meet you nice to meet you I like your
shirt thank you are you a big AC DC fan
I just like the shirt oh no I've heard
I've heard back in Black a few times
sometimes movies I'm very much like a
Marvel type person so but what if what
if you wear that shirt and you find out
that they're like a white supremacist
metal but like acid rock band
I don't know I mean that's where you
kind of like you do your history right
it sounds like you haven't done on AC DC
they're not by the way they see my
decent people I'm just saying I get it
it's always my dad says the same thing
he's like you need to research and I'm
like sometimes okay I did it once when I
was a kid I got a Grateful Dead shirt at
a thrift store and I liked it because I
had Mr Saturday the skeleton or the top
hat and then someone's like hey A
Grateful Dead That's I was like who's
grateful I won't listen to them and they
sucked and I was like oh I can't believe
I wore that shirt out in public so uh
anai I don't know how familiar you are
if at all with the change of mind
segments it's basically designed to
hopefully rationalize our positions on
seemingly controversial topics they've
been actually pretty uh pretty friendly
today which is a good thing I'm really
happy about that so today
um let me kind of state my position
I do not believe that women should be in
combat roles winning roles where they
would encounter physical violence
enlisted forces infantry or in the
police force where they would have to be
so doing violent perpetrators because it
not only is less safe for them it's less
safe for their brothers and arms and
it's less safe for us as a country the
citizens are sworn to protect I
specifically say women
I support a physical meritocracy but we
have only lowered the standards to allow
more women into the military and police
force for us so that's why I have a
problem specifically with women in
combat roles who can meet lower physical
requirements and still get the same job
okay if you disagree with that or you
think I missed something I'd love to
hear you
I'll just hold it just because we've had
people try and steal them oh no I'm not
saying you would but but I I I believe
that I strongly disagree just based off
my family's experience I have multiple
cousins my grandparents were in the
military so I have both men and women in
my family in the military
um I don't think that
certain regulations or rules that they
change now are in benefit of women or
men I don't think I think it's an
betterment of the troops together as a
whole because you think of them as our
military is as one they don't see oh
you're black you're white or you're a
woman or a man when it comes down to
combat I
one thing that my grandfather has told
me when he was in combat was he's like I
didn't care who it was right I don't
care it'd be like you're my brother
you're my sister I'ma save you and make
sure you're okay regardless of man woman
black white asian Hispanic whatever this
is your grandfather yes well I think
your grandfather said that because your
grandfather sounds like a very decent
man
um well unfortunately he has passed away
but it sounds like a good man
um here's the issue like you said it
doesn't see color and as a matter of
fact there's it's true it's actually
kind of a beautiful thing in the
military it's very mixed as far as
demographics a lot of black Americans a
lot of uh Hispanic Americans
um
however it's not blind when it applies
to women they can meet far lower PT
requirements do you think so no it's
absolutely true so they low they created
separate standards for men and women
starting in the 70s and then recently
the Army tried to create a
gender-neutral test less than 10 of men
failed 65 of women failed for example in
the Marines a woman can do half as many
pull-ups as a man and get a perfect
score we've eliminated push-ups we've
eliminated pull-ups we've eliminated the
leg tuck we've now moved to the plank
because women were not passive
um
if we're talking about them all as one
my issue is that it's not blind it is
creating a separate lower standard for
women to join the same combat roles
how does that make those out there in
the front lines safer to have someone
who's less qualified less capable but
because they're a woman they get the
same spot well I mean I think it also
kind of depends on
like when you come in like there's you
have to think about it like hey there's
a lot of high schools that go straight
into the military because that's their
one option or that's the option that
they choose so
just as any corporate job would be like
you have your entry level be like that's
kind of the same thing with the military
now for like my cousin she went in the
military she did her training and
everything like that and she's moved up
the ranks and she had to meet a far
lower physical requirement I don't I
don't think so I mean I'll have to call
her and ask her but I don't believe so
that's the policy of issuing the Army no
which branch is she Air Force Air Force
yeah it's the policy of Army Air Force
Marines I won't have to ask her but I
don't let's assume it's let's assume
that what I'm saying is not untrue let's
assume for the sake of argument that for
example women can meet a much lower
physical requirement and not only
physical but certain mental requirements
reflex requirements that women can
achieve a far lower
score or they even have to meet far
lower physical standards let's say
that's the case
I'm telling you I'm giving you my word
it is the case with the Marines it is
the case with the Army it is the case
with Municipal police forces so let's
assume that's true that for example a
man has to do let's just say 10 pull-ups
and a woman can do five or none and
achieve the same score
[Music]
what are your thoughts do you think
that's I don't think
as far as you debating like the certain
requirements I don't think that a that's
fair I think that I feel like in my mind
I feel like they should be a basis for
everybody same standard same standard I
agree rather it's you do 20 push-ups if
you do meet the 20 then hey you're good
I agree but I don't think that I don't
think it's fair to men or women yes now
to put say because there are some women
who can do 25 push-ups burpees and all
these types of things and complete the
whole the whole nine years that's why we
lowered the standards for but I don't
it is absolutely true the military
requirements are far far lower for women
see for me I would have to see the
statistics the writing every every
policy that there is to actually
understand and see what you're saying
because I'm the person type person but
if that is true you would disagree with
it yeah
yeah I would disagree that there
shouldn't be there shouldn't be a
difference right there should be a plain
board for everyone to meet the
requirements right regardless I agree
but as far as the whole thing of like
mental stability and all this type of
stuff I think that's attacking women as
just a gender's character
because yes
I mean no but it's just like
when people swim I when I hear people
like well I don't believe women should
be in the military or I don't believe
women should be in combat it's I've
always heard that oh they're emotional
or there's certain like biological
practice like oh well they get pregnant
well those are true those are true but
I'm like
that is an issue I mean but just as men
are like men are emotional men have bad
days the fact they can't get pregnant
but I was like they can also get injured
so I'm like for certain things like it's
interesting you bring that up because
women the bone fracture rate far far
higher for women when they're out there
in the field their their disability
discharge rate is up on the 60 something
percent higher than men and like I think
percentage of men from the military
discharge you get PTSD it's in the
single digits for women it's over 10. so
it's not an attack on their character
these are statistical realities but also
it's kind of an effective
not just the combat issue but it's also
the fact of other men in the military
taking a stance against that woman it's
I don't think that's what it is and
women need to deal with being animals if
they're if they're in a foxhole with
animals they got to be an animal and
women I think that's where I think
that's where it's
which a we're humans that's what we're
humans don't don't compare anybody to
animal because we're not in Wartime you
need to be a beast I get it but I'm just
saying like I don't think that's a
correct way to describe or build a
conversation of well this is a
war is war war is a mental game
physiological game of combat strategies
all that so you have to be smart you
have to think quick and I get it yes
there's a physical Factor
just as some men some men cannot handle
it I agree just as there are some women
who cannot handle it there are women who
can handle and there are men who can't
handle it there are very few women who
can a lot of men can so very few women
who came in with statistic or how what
percentage of women who cannot handle
the military yeah so when they had them
it's this we have such little data on
for example the standards in the Army
where you had to do a certain amount of
Pull-Up certain amount of push-ups
certain amount of sit-ups you had to do
your run uh depending on the year how
many miles you have to meet a certain
time uh
single digit percentage of women who
could make it okay what is that number
though so the number was between one and
five okay okay but it's a really small
sample pool because to get women in
combat roles it only started when they
immediately lowered the PT requirements
so we lowered them to the point where
okay no more push-ups for example in the
Army uh no more pull-ups at all you
could do a leg tuck too many women
failed that so they could do a plank
in the Marines women can do half as many
pull-ups achieve a perfect score then
what happened is a lot of women were
complaining because they felt singled
out because at a standard for men and
they had a standard for women and when
we're still failing so they created a
gender-neutral test that was the same
test for men and women kind of between
the two standards which I disagree with
I think it should be the higher standard
less than 10 percent of men failed 65
percent of women failed
55 to 65 failed a gender neutral test
designed to accommodate women there is
no way to lower the standards anymore
and still have women in physical combat
roles we have lowered the standards of
physical combat Readiness to a degree
that frankly is embarrassing to
accommodate women and they still the
majority of them still fail
and assuming that I'm not lying
right and I would encourage you to go do
the research on the PT requirements
sounds to me like you and I agree sounds
to me like you and I agree there should
be one standard it should be a stringent
standard right because they're going out
to war
and if you're a man and you fail you
don't make it and if you're a woman and
you fail you don't make it will we both
agree on that yeah okay that's that's
all I'm saying yeah I just think that
that's not the law we have a separate
standard for women and it's much much
lower which I would argue is sexist so
we both agree the only issue is I think
you're not fully familiar with the new
military policy you disagree with
military policy and so do I I think we
would be in the same boat saying why are
we having separate standards I just
think it's where you
single out we like well women because
it's a different standard for women I
think my thing is like this if it's a
someone's dream to serve their country
rather but let's not just talk about the
military let's talk about the police
force sure there are women there are a
lot especially in Dallas Denton County
there are a lot of women
in the police force sure that have made
it through become Chief has power
standards I don't think so yes because
just because but if they are assuming
you can say you don't think so but
respectfully if it is the fact and
you're looking at going hey there's a
male police officer and there's a female
police officer but she only has to be
half as capable
that's a problem
it's not an accomplishment I don't care
if it's her dream she's going to run
into a guy my size on PCP
she'll get hurt and statistically she is
more likely to get hurt that's my issue
I don't think
that it should be someone else now if
the government makes a ruling saying
whatever that's fine but I don't think
as people in a society where our police
force or our military is being
questioned rather than men or women I
think that
you should stand by that person
be like if a woman in the middle in the
military or that the police force is
there and you see something going on
okay that she that's their job from what
that's their job they get paid to do
that so it's not it I don't think that
it's your you have the right to think
whatever you want but I don't think you
should be able to
really question rather that person is
doing their job capable when you haven't
put yourself on that line or have not
experience objectively they're not as
qualified
I don't think you're right but you just
agreed with me that we should have the
same standards I believe that we should
yes the police force we should have a
lower standard for women there is no
We're not gonna have a conversation if
you just say reality isn't reality
that's reality then show me the
statistics that's my that's my thing I'm
not going to believe a single word
you're saying until I see the paper or I
see the statistics in front of my face
okay
except
all right and we have them the third
party references but these are all
linking you can see kind of where
they're linking to as far as studies
all right
so the army army scrap the gender
neutral test due to women failing at six
times higher rate than men you can find
this at U.S news and committee later you
can find the studies okay the Army
eliminated pull-ups in 1980 sit-ups in
2020 push-ups in 2020. females can do
half as many pull-ups to get a perfect
score in the military integrated units
all male units demonstrated higher
performance levels on 93 of 134 compared
to gender integrated units gender
integrated units performed better than
male units on only two events I actually
need to correct myself because earlier I
think I said four events I was overly
generous increased violence this is
something where you can actually find
it's tough with police unlike the
military with police forces because it's
more Municipal so they have different
databases so give me some advice for
that increasing the number of female
officers by one percentage Point
increases the number of assaults on
police by 15 to 19 percent
uh so this is what we're coming down to
these numbers are irrefutable we have
the physical standard numbers we also
have the bone mineral density numbers we
have the fact that women unfortunately
suffer bone fractures at a much higher
rate in the military and that women and
also their brother and arms the men near
them are more likely to be the victim of
violent attack
um and a big part of that is because
criminals no unfortunately they can
overpower women because male criminals
are often stronger than women especially
when you add to the component illegal
stimulants uh
and that leaves everyone less safe so
these are the stats and they will be
made publicly available assuming that I
am not lying and that we have a double
standard and one that is incredibly low
for women to meet assuming that this is
true you now have the stats in front of
your face
we agreed before that it should be one
standard and you either meet it or you
don't do we still both agree on that yes
okay that's what then that's what I want
to see legislatively because right now
it's not right now there's a double
standard one for men one for women and I
think um I don't know if you've ever
competed in athletics at all uh what
sports did you volleyball and soccer did
you have knee surgeries nope oh good
you're lucky every girl I know who did
volleyball
had horrible knee surgeries it's tough
on the body it's not it's incredible
incredibly difficult sport
um when we look for example at uh at
sports obviously there's a difference
between men and women would we agree
there's a reason that they're separated
I mean I've competed in coed and I've
completed in just female sports and
honestly the co-ed one for me it was
more fun be it
was I feel like with sports is different
because at least with soccer for example
women are very more competitive
at least from when I played and it's
very very much just like just like
football for men soccer is very much a
contact sport for females and it's very
rough playing out there yeah the Women's
National Team they lose to high school
boys every year
like the U.S national team of soccer yes
sir the ones the high school boys the
one that got a world championship before
the men they lose to high school boys
if you show it to me then I'll see it oh
sure just just uh search women's
national soccer team do you want to do
it if you bring it up on your phone I
don't I don't have my phone on me okay
I'm sure I can bring it up women's
national soccer team
so I'm just it's just and I appreciate
you asking I'm glad that you're actually
questioning it but I don't have a good
reception here so look you can see me
typing this in yes
women's
so I'll just type in soccer team
soccer team
High School
boys okay if we have reception here
FC Dallas under 15 boys squat this is
from CBS Sports beat the U.S women's
national team okay
and this is not a singular event it
occurs all the time now
they still are impressive for women
but they're not men they're not even
high school boys
take that add the consequences of death
or subduing a man here for example in an
area of Dallas you know late at night
that's catastrophic for women I don't
think that's progress and I think we
agree I just want the policy to reflect
that we should have standards that are
difficult right that are certainly high
if we're talking about people in
physical roles that require physically
extraordinary capabilities whether
you're a man or woman
you pass it or you don't and then we
would look at the real world data and
see how it plays out out there in the
field that is all I'm asking right now
we are doing the opposite of that as a
matter of policy
and that leads to unfortunately women in
compromised situations I guess my
question is
in this argument because I've heard not
just you and and I'm not what I'm trying
I'm not trying to just base your
argument off other arguments no I don't
understand but when I hear some of these
other arguments it's well it's in the
betterment of women or
in a kind of a sexist role women
shouldn't
shouldn't be in these roles because it
is a man's job
why I guess besides the statistics and
besides you feel like women get hurt men
get hurt what is the true point of this
well I don't feel they do
we could disagree or no we can't
disagree just like we can't disagree
that 15 year old boys beat the Women's
National Team there's no disagreement
it's the truth anyway
well you told me you didn't think it was
true okay
let me are you gonna let me finish well
I know what I'm saying there's
disagreeing and there's truth right we
need to agree on objections
when
you showed me the statistics you showed
me the soccer
it's on the news it's it's on Public
Information where I can go look it up
and go see sure I'm not disagreeing
disagreeing that okay but besides the
point of those statistics
what
is it just the biological
just the biological anatomy of women
that you believe that should not be in
combat rather it's like you said you
said the bone density they're more you
said something strengths bone density
endurance anaerobic capacity ability to
perform reflexively under stress any
physical metric that you can use to
apply to the most effective fighting
force the vast majority of women fail
miserably in comparison to me and what
does that compare to other countries
I I haven't looked up all of the other
countries but if you believe that for
example a Lithuanian woman is much
stronger than American woman and the men
are weaker and that differential is
closed
I just I would be very hard-pressed to
believe it no because I'm saying like
you like you have the statistics for our
military have you done your research on
our military versus other military
either women or men
well it's a very large sample size so
why would that change anything and as it
relates to our military I think the
stats are enough reality is enough I'm
saying like comparative to English
military where they have women in combat
too yeah where did where I'm guessing
what I'm saying is where does that stand
where the that's the same rule I would
say you still need to have the same
standard I'm not saying the different
standards or I'm saying like
statistically where are they at where
you do your research and you
comparatively compare it to others yeah
that's where I'm questioning that's
where my question is yeah I would
imagine that they also have lowered
their physical standards they either
have a lower standard for women or
they've created a gender-neutral test so
women can pass and I would be willing to
bet my life that far fewer women pass
than men on standards of physical rigor
across the world well maybe you should
do your research and compare it to the
United States that's that's my only
thing is like when people give these
supports because I'm dealing with
American policy I know and we agree on
the American policy of being silly
there should be a one standard right we
agree on that I don't think it's silly
now yes I think there should be reform
yes but rather that reform comes in the
next five years or so we don't know
statistically what you've shown me it
looks like yes we need to reform sooner
than later but that's not a that's not
up to us yes it is it's exactly up to us
it's exactly up to us that's my point
it's up to you you don't have to get
close it's up to both of us okay
you're an American citizen yeah you can
vote
I can vote
right
the policy right now is
lower standards for women because the
government believes that women are so
incapable they need to have such low
physical standards applied so if you
disagree with that then I think it is up
to us I mean like yes but is it to
enforce it that's that's up to the top
people that's them and rather they see
the statistics or not and decide to put
that on the ballot this
and me that's that's why I'm doing this
I don't believe that we should just
defer the Elites in power I don't know
if you know what the elites and power
have done horrible things they've been
they've been racist they actually have
been sexist I would argue their military
standards now are sexist it only changes
from the ground up
we have to hold them accountable they're
not going to be held accountable until
people like you and myself if we agree
on something make sure that it's hurt
and they have to listen it is up to us I
think that's important because a lot of
students here seem to have a disconnect
that no those are those people in power
I I also have to think we some of us
just came from high school so sure and
some of us are just now turning 18 where
we can't vote so there is a disconnect
and they're sure and that's where a lot
of things also education wise there's
not a lot of education on policies
political things it's very apparent yeah
on campus so
it's
there's a lot of things that just not
this one subject that needs to be talked
about I think that I think I believe
that there's more important things than
can women be in combat that we need to
focus on
like
schooling like let's make sure like kids
have meals let's make sure that kids are
all getting the same education before we
start talking about other things well
I've done many of these and we have done
them on school choice for example I'm a
huge supporter of school choice and
school vouchers
um we have done them on abortion we have
done them on gender we've done them on a
multitude of topics we have done them on
gun rights this is just one today I get
it it's just one today but I'm just
saying like I just believe like
that I believe like the way that it's
phrased
I think it could be phrased better but
I mean it is what it is but I like we
said we can disagree on policies need to
be on across the board well I think we
agree yeah yeah I said that's common
ground there yeah no yes I believe that
we should that it should be across the
board
as far as
the choice I I that's well I don't think
there's any choice the test is what it
is it's blind but I'm saying but if
women wants to be in combat that's their
choice not if they don't pass a test you
can't maintain both of those positions
you can't say there should be a standard
they have to pass and then say or it's
their choice then we'll have a test
you're saying if they pass the test yes
that's what I meant okay if they pass
the test that's your choice I agree if
they decide to you know what you know
what combat's not for me for me whatever
because
but if they pass the test yes if they
don't they don't have a choice it's like
yes you're out but I'm like there's so
many different things in the military
rally you say army marines whatever
there's there's so many different tests
that they have to take rather it's and
different roles by the way yeah to be
clear I think that I'm not saying that
women should not be in the military I
think I've been clear or the police
force I don't want them to be in a
situation where they will encounter
physical violence if they're not
physically capable women can be
detectives they can be interrogators
they can be negotiators they can do
fantastic work with Intel they can be
operating drones they can be Pilots I'm
just talking about roles that have
physical standards or did for a reason
so do you think the same way when it
comes to operating like a gun or any
type of
no no here's the thing I think that I
actually am a huge advocate of women
carrying firearms I think that women
should because it's the one thing that
actually makes you stronger than a man
it's an equalizer if a man is attempting
to rape a woman sexually assault or
overpower a woman her best chance is to
carry a firearm the flip side of that is
why I want female police officers to
have to meet the same standards as men
because if they're not physically
capable they have to go to their gun
right if it's a big strong man on drugs
her only option is her gun for the same
reason I think it's good for you to have
an unfair advantage in day-to-day life
if someone breaks into your house women
should have guns police officers need to
be ultra physically capable so they
don't have to use their guns so that
they can de-escalate so we have less
police brutality I want fewer police
having to use their firearms or use
their taser in the same case of when you
say that
yes like when you say bring up police
brutality but I see as as a black person
I see more men getting grabbing the
white police officer men grabbing their
guns when it's in defense of a black
person
rather it's a woman or a man yeah that's
a topic for another day but
statistically yeah it's actually um uh
when you're talking about armed white
men are actually more likely to be shot
by officers and than black men
but we did a whole we've done a whole
table on that yes but either way I think
we would both agree it would be one
standard it would be ideal that a police
officer is capable in de-escalation
right and psychologically and physically
so they can subdue someone without
having to use a gun I think for me my
opinion is regardless if it's
if it's a police officer regardless of
man or woman if I see a badge if I see
the uniform I'm gonna go to them for
help that's one thing I don't care if
you're a man or a woman
that that's honestly one thing I care
about I don't care no yes I would hope
that their training has been enough to
where they are capable if I am getting
attacked that they can help me
fight off the attacker or whatever but
as far as that I think right now until
the policies change until we like you
said everyone votes and makes their
decision on where they stand sure until
then I feel like there should be one
thing of okay
just because she's a female does not
mean that she cannot help me and I think
that's where some I think I never said
that and no not you but I think some
I've heard that from some other guys or
some other men who were like well she's
a female officer or they're they're a
female officer that I don't think
they're still doing their job I don't
think they're saying she's a female and
I'll leave you with us I don't think
they're saying she's a female officer
she can't she can't help me I think what
people are saying is she's a female
officer she did not have to meet the
same physical requirements ooh it's a
roll of the dice I don't know how much
he's going to be able to help me and
that's based on a reality and I think
that that is horrible because women will
forever be held in doubt because of the
diversity higher and the double standard
for the same reason that affirmative
action in college is a problem because
unfortunately people will go that person
deserve to be here or is an affirmative
action result and I think that that's
the bigotry of low expectations and yeah
unfortunately it harms women and
unfortunately a lot of these situations
they harm people of color and I think
that the tests need to be blind we need
to have a standardized test
regardless of race or gender if you pass
great and of course I think we should
respect everyone who's out there who's
serving who's doing their job honestly
they're a police officer I wouldn't
denigrate or disrespect them I agree
with you on that thank you so much
though I appreciate you sitting down and
I do like the sweater go listen they
have some great albums if you haven't
listened to them I think you might like
them I mean I have to do homework so oh
I'm not saying right now but
but uh thank you very much Anaya yes
Anaya got it
see it's always hard to have a
discussion when the opposing point of
view insists that your research is
simply made up and it's why it's always
valuable to have the references and make
them available which by the way you can
go see for yourselves at loudoun.com
also ladies small bit of advice take it
or leave it when your loving father
suggests that you do something like
research your AC DC sweater not a bad
idea to listen to them dads tend to know
best especially when it comes to music
from their era okay let's bring this
Tugboat to Shore and see if we can
finish this on a high note oh yeah we
have two lovely ladies here Jewel and
Caitlin I don't know how familiar you
are at all with what we do with them
these segments he's changed my mind it's
hopefully a way where people can kind of
rationalize their positions on sometimes
controversial topics uh yeah I don't
believe uh that women should be in
combat roles and like you mentioned
police officer roles if it's a role that
includes violence or the possibility of
being physically overpowered or enlisted
forces roles because of the fact that it
makes Not only women unsafe who are in
the line of fire but also their their
brothers and arms less safe I think
there are multitude of ways that women
can serve in the military and in the
police force but those that require you
know physical extraordinary physical
capabilities are not amongst them
um and if you disagree with that you
might be more than happy to hear why and
you change my mind well I'm not really
the type of person and be like what you
think is like wrong and what I think is
right like I'm open to hearing other
people's like perspectives on things I'm
not really like no you think we don't
think the same year wrong you know great
so what I get what I'm like hearing from
you is like I'm not necessarily hearing
like women are better or women men are
better and women aren't it's just like
the the physical attributes of what's
different yes so
um okay you sang by like they shouldn't
be in physical roles how do you think
like that do you think like
I don't know what I'm trying to say do
you think that women can
um
I don't know work up to being physically
capable like so yeah and that's a that's
something that kind of expect people to
to bring up um statistically very
unlikely
um and that's the reason for this topic
is you know we've created different
tests since the 70s you know 60s 70s 80s
90s where we've reduced the physical
requirements to try and accommodate
women and they still fail at a rate
that's significantly higher than several
multiples higher than men
um I mean they even just created a
gender-neutral test in the army that
they now have to scrap because less than
10 percent of men were failing but 65 of
women were failing and these are tests
that no longer include pull-ups push-ups
and if you look at the results uh once
they get out into the field of battle
women get hurt a lot more and members of
their squad get hurt a lot more and they
suffer bone fracture rates at several
times you know multiple rate they get
disability discharges so 65 more than
men in the police force they're far more
likely in their whole Squad to be
violently attacked if there's a woman
there and in large part it's because
this is a role that requires physical
capabilities so if we're saying if women
could meet those standards yeah my
position I would agree with you if it's
we raise it to the highest standards
that we've had keep those and women who
can meet those sure but that's not what
we're doing right I think it's
inherently sexist to keep lowering the
physical standards to try and
accommodate women and combat roles yeah
even though they still keep failing and
it ends up putting them In Harm's Way
I had a question I forgot it do you
think that
um
by cut like what like what are you like
what's your goal like here like account
what are you trying to like accomplish
here well I think this is the goal and
these uh change our minds started out
actually just me kind of on the street
with a sign okay and then we had a
couple on campus
and then it became very apparent that no
one on campus was hearing these
perspectives for example we've done them
on gender we've done them on gun rights
we've done them on abortion so it's
really just hopefully
um for the the student body to no longer
be a monolith and hear different
perspectives because this is a pretty
important idea
I do agree that the body like was
genetically not made for that kind of
thing you know like like
resulting back to like very old times
you know women were never made to do
that like the men would do that or the
men would go to fire or whatever and the
woman would cook or clean or whatever
that kind of thing so well I'm not
saying that women have to just to be
clear I'm not saying I have to cook or
clean there's no reason that a woman for
example in the police can't be a
detective it can't be a forensic
investigator there's some data to
suggests they might be better um they
might be better interrogators actually
so I have no problem with that I have a
problem with putting women and we are
doing this in combat roles where not
only they are more likely to be hurt but
their brothers and arms are more likely
to be hurt as a result of someone who's
unqualified being put on the force okay
so I'm not saying they should be at home
cooking there are many many ways that
women can serve in the military in the
police force just not physically I agree
okay um so like is this topic coming
from you from a place of I think men are
better and women are less inferior or
where is it coming from no no I
understand look
men are not Superior to women and women
are not Superior to men we're different
yeah I don't know that we're doing any
uh any great service to young women by
telling them that they can do anything a
man can do
just like we're telling young men that
men can get pregnant too I don't believe
they can yeah absolutely but we've done
that topic as well and we've had people
say that I'm transphobic for suggesting
that
um and I think that there are rules in
which you know women serve valuably and
they have in the military and in the
police force but I think this idea that
everyone has to be equal on all fronts
is I really think it's it's harmful I
honestly agree because like like
recently like with the whole like like
the gender topping and everything like
there's been a lot of topic of some like
feminist women like um
being like like we
scientifically don't necessarily need
men anymore for what they add to like
creating children and everything like
that like it can genetically create like
children for women and put them in their
bellies and everything in a lab you know
but then if you think about it and you
look at the the bigger picture like like
in the trades field most of the trades
workers are men yeah if you look at what
they're doing in the oil field
um welding all types of construction
work all types of that like I'm not
saying women can't do it like if you
want to do it you you just have to work
10 times harder but that's something if
you want to do you can do but if you
look at it like like most women wouldn't
pick to do that and if you get rid of
men like who would be doing that who
would make up you know 93 of all the
workplace deaths built the building
behind us who would fix you know like
like the World Trade Center whenever
when that happened like most of the
firefighters and the police officers and
everything were men right saving
people's lives and everything like that
like yeah I just feel like
um God made a God made a man and woman
for one reason you know men are supposed
to do this women are about to do this
and I do agree that men are more
physically capable yeah what do you
think about um it sounds like we find we
found quite a bit of Common Ground most
people aren't aware but what do you
think about the fact that we've
continually lowered you know physical
requirements for the military so that
women can meet I feel like it makes I
feel like putting our men out there with
a lower physical requirement it makes it
easier for people to get in who may not
be able to buy it as well or like
physically be physically
inclined enough to go out there and
fight the war you know if they lower
that standard you know it should be set
at a standard that all of them should be
able to
um you know just fit in that same
category where is it they keep on
lowering it I mean it just makes our men
out there week and weaker yeah I think
that like like changing the whole like
um requirements and everything like that
like it's given people the mindset of
like
like I can do this now because like it's
changed when I feel like if they would
have just left it alone and they would
have left it at the same like you have
to do this a b or c or you can't get in
you know like if they would have just
left it at that like like there are some
bad badass women that could have done it
and they could have gone in you know
like I'm not saying like it's a large
percentage or a small percentage or
anything but I am saying there are some
women that could do it and then that
would just make it even more rewarding I
feel like everybody gets the same
opportunity nowadays when necessarily
they don't deserve that they don't work
as hard they can't physically do it you
know like I know for a fact if I tried
right now to go join the military I
would not get it no well no absolutely
not you know and I don't think it's fair
that you know I would correct it it's
not that it's not fair that it's not
right because people do this because
they say it's fair but when we go into
that a lot of people don't know this for
example in the Marines a woman can do
half as many pull-ups as a man and get a
perfect score I don't think that's fair
I think it needs to be the same standard
because yeah may seem unfair but it's it
looks right but it shouldn't be the same
standard because that lowers the
standard for the man exactly right well
if that's the thing is it's not the same
in the Marines they don't have a gender
neutral test in the Marines a man has to
do twice as many pull-ups to get a
perfect score so a woman can do half and
get a perfect score but they're out
there in the same Battlefield fighting
the same enemy that's very true and I
know that I'll I've been accused and I
will continue to be accused of sexism
and maintaining my position but I just
don't want to see a woman who can't do
pull-ups out there get her head caved in
you know because she's she's not
qualified to be there right it comes
with deadly ramifications
um but I think the it does come from
also like a different like um mental
state as well that's true that plays a
big women are far more likely actually
to experience like PTSD be discharged
for that and that's not to say that
women are mentally weaker is to say that
women are mentally I would argue more
Adept at other situations that men
wouldn't handle very well exactly going
out there with a gun and fighting
terrorists where you're not able to
shower and you're not eating for days as
one of those that were test after Test
shows that men perform better but not
when it comes to making sure that uh you
know as you mentioned like children are
taken care of I mean I'm a new dad
basically all I do for the first years
make sure they don't die I'm pretty much
useless they don't really need me yeah
so uh I think different a lot to do the
genetic makeup in general like it just
results all the way back to the the
genetic makeup like that's just how a
man is built
is built like I just feel like
physically women are way more inclined
do you think most women on this campus
would agree with your position
absolutely absolutely no why not so
Women's University uh they're very very
well I know what you're saying but
explain what that means
um people here are very
um I would say liberal
maybe not liberal person maybe I don't
know just because I don't know I would
say more like crazy
more emotionally in touch people are
sensitive yeah like more emotionally in
touch with like who would have expected
that at a Women's University they're
just a lot more
I don't know I guess just like
yeah I'm more emotionally involved with
these kind of things like oh that's
they're going to tell you that you're
sexist and they're going they're like oh
you know people come here like women can
do anything you know like yeah sure
women can do anything but that doesn't
mean that we're not genetically made to
not be women can't do anything though
nor can men I don't know why that's men
can't give birth and statistics women
can't do pull-ups yeah I mean there's
just so many things that a man is made
for versus a woman and people don't hear
don't see the difference in that like
people in here people here just because
of the generation we're growing up in in
the generation we're becoming do you
have these so you say that your your
position might be less than popular on a
campus like this yeah let me ask you
this because women for the same reason
they're more agreeable right women tend
to be nicer they don't tend to be as
confrontational do you have these
conversations do you challenge your
female classmates when these topics come
up or do you just kind of try and
sidestep don't associate myself with I
don't know it's like you already know
how the conversation is gonna go so it's
like topic like this it's like you just
like
again like my opinions are my opinions
your opinions are your opinions people
are so too sensitive nowadays to be like
well your opinion's wrong no my opinion
isn't wrong we're different people
that's just how can I present something
to you just just as a thought yeah
because first off I think that you've uh
presented yourselves well thank you and
you've rationalized your positions well
thank you but I would say this
you saying that's your opinion and this
is my opinion that's very respectful but
here's the problem the people with these
other opinions we were talking about on
campus they're the ones determining
legislation because often people like
you I don't mean that in a denigrating
way being respectful you decide well
Live and Let Live but these other people
don't that's very true they're pushing
it legislatively to the point where
children are allowed on puberty blockers
and so that's very true I'm told right
no vagina no opinion
um even though women obviously have
opinions on men's issues all the time we
need women like you having those
conversations and making sure that you
can kind of push back on the legislative
process because it is dominated by the
kinds of people you're mentioning
I kind of gravitate towards people who
think the same as me like for summer I
just I don't do it on purpose just like
I just kind of feel like
the whole confrontation thing is just
something you try to avoid it's
exhausting I'm a very confrontational
person and if yes someone were to come
to me and say and tell me my opinion's
wrong I'd be like well a man can get
pregnant like absolutely no or like I
can I can turn into a guy if I want to
like I just don't think that that is
physically okay all I ask is that you
have those conversations here on campus
Because unfortunately you know women
I say this there's no group of people
maybe black Americans who are more
overly represented in the media but
whose voice is actually completely
unrepresented uh than women because
everyone sees them they assume right
that when they talk about women voting
it's Pro Roe v Wade Pro lgbtq and
women's sports you know progressivism as
opposed to any type of traditional
gender roles and that doesn't mean that
they're fixed but meaning that
recognizing differences between men and
women it's assumed that women are a
monolith and unfortunately I think a big
part of it is because women like you are
nice which is you'd still be nice but
don't be afraid to speak out right
because I'm sure you feel it right I'm
sure you feel a little bit of that
tension to speak out and you maybe
you'll be ostracized right there is some
pressure I'd imagine
you know like everybody I feel like
thinks one way right and I went to a
different Universe I'm a transfer
student so I went to Howard Payne
University in Brownwood Texas I don't
know if you know where that is but do
you know where Tarleton is Tarleton
Tarleton is no well it's in Stephenville
Brownwood is an hour away and the campus
and the campus life and the community
completely different if you were to have
this same conversation there you would
get completely different answers and it
would honestly be less contra reversial
there but the majority of students are
male students that are white I would say
though having done this that's actually
never been the case because even if
let's say the student body is more
varied in their points of view it ends
up being a few people who dominate the
conversation yeah because they're on any
campus they're the ones that want the
confrontation that are have a different
view yes yeah so well thank you very
much I'm sure your names again were my
name is Caitlin Caitlin Jewell Jewel
thank you for saying I hope I clarify
the business I really appreciate you
taking the time of course